-Last time you were on the show,
we talked about the fact
that you had a very nice cameo
in "The Irishman."
Got to do some work
with De Niro.
-Yeah, a little bit
of walk and talk with him.
-You did a really nice job
You were selling caskets.
-Yeah, you know,
as they say in the business,
it was a walk and talk.
Solo. Me, one on one with Bobby.
You know, Marty was over there
talking to us,
letting us know,
"Just be yourself."
That's what he told me.
-Hey, Action, are you doin
curls with your phone right now?
Because it's just going
up and down.
-It's going up --
Nah, I'm excited.
And then my fingers,
they just do what they want.
I'm sorry. I have jazz hands
Pardon me. I'm trying
to hold it as steady --
-You have jazz hands right now
-I do.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm trying to hold it
as steady as possible.
So, yeah.
I mean, to be honest, being on a
movie set is just unbelievable
especially with
those types of legends.
And I just -- I can't even
believe that it happened.
-It was amazing.
And I think you must've picked
up some stuff from those guys,
must've refined your chops
because the next time
I saw you in a movie,
"King of Staten Island"...
-Oh, that's right.
-...scene stealer.
A scene-stealing performance
-Ooh! Oh, that makes me
feel really good.
Thank you very much, sir.
I mean, you know, listen,
they gave me a big opportunity
you know? Pete --
I went in there with him
and Judd and a bunch of people
and we kind of, like,
just went back and forth,
just talking [bleep]
And they loved me,
and that was that.
I came in there, and I kne
Marisa Tomei was in the scene,
so I had to step up.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-You know what I mean?
-That's a high bar.
Marisa Tomei is the high bar
-Well, just put it this way.
I've been in a movie now
with Joe Pesci and Marisa Tomei.
-You're doing --
You almost got the full Vinny.
-"My Cousin Vinny."
Now I need Ralph Macchio.
-You get a Macchio,
and then it's the full Vinny
That's every -- [ Laughs ]
-Oh, man.
It was like I was a fireman,
but I wasn't.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
-I hadn't gone through
the training.
-You are getting
in fireman shape.
And, you know,
we know you from --
as someone
who likes the good life.
You like to indulge
in good foods
and maybe not often
the healthiest foods.
But you are indeed
eating healthier.
You are imbibing
of the green juice.
How has the green juice
treated you?
-The green juice
is a beautiful thing.
Kale, celery, green apple,
ginger, little lemon.
It's one of the greatest thing
on earth.
It's lowered my cholesterol.
It's taken away any chance
of diabetic situations.
I've lost like
80 [bleep] pounds, man.
80 pounds is a lot of weight
And I'm still fat.
So, like I said, it shows yo
that I was a fat ass [bleep]
-[ Laughs ]
-Right now,
I'm just an ass [bleep]
-Did you take to green juice
right away,
or did you have to develop
a taste for it?
-Nah, I still don't like it.
I don't like it.
I just pound it.
I put as much as I can
into a huge, like, milk ju
and then just down it
with a metal straw.
I don't know.
There's just certain techniques.
-Now, I have to ask,
maybe you'll be out on the roa
soon hopefully touring.
Maybe you'll be doing anothe
season of the show, God willing.
But if -- When this ends,
when restaurants are open
and everything is robust again
where is the first place tha
Action Bronson's going to go
-Oh, my Lord.
It's sad to say,
but we've learned --
just all these places, you know,
like, this is all pleasure
This is all pleasure.
We could all get by withou
this stuff, and it's sad to say.
But Don Pepe's would be th
first place I'm going in Queens.
-Yeah.
-Stuffed peppers,
chicken parm, linguini clams
That's when I get to my goal
30 more pounds to go,
and then I'm going to allo
myself to have some fun.
-30 pounds is going to line up
right with vaccine,
restaurants open, a perfect --
And you're going to go
to Don Pepe's.
Ralph Macchio
is going to be there.
The whole world is going
to shine its light on you.
-It's all going to come
to one -- to a head.
-Hey, it's always a pleasure
to see you, buddy.
-Man, you, too.
-Congrats on the show.
You're looking good.
-Thank you, bro.
-And hopefully next time
in person.
-I can't wait. Much love.
Thank you for having me again,
as always.
You're the best.
-Alright. Thanks, Action.
-I can't wait to bring octopus
towards you again.
[ Both laugh ]
-Deal.